okay big news from last night President
Obama experienced the first veto
override of his presidency nearly eight
years into his presidency so that is an
accomplishment in and of itself
President Obama previously vetoed
legislation which would allow relatives
of nine eleven victims to sue Saudi
Arabia when the president vetoes a bill
the House and Senate can then come
together and vote to override that veto
and that is exactly what happened last
night the House of Representatives voted
348 277 against President Obama's veto
and uh also the Senate voted 97 21 to
reject that veto meaning that the
justice against sponsors of terrorism
act will indeed become the law what this
law will do is grant an exception
there's this legal principle called
sovereign immunity in cases of terrorism
on us soul soil meaning if people from
foreign country X come to the US and
commit an act of terror Americans are
not able to sue country X because the
people who did the act of terror came
from their country this law will create
an exception to that legal principle
Saudi Arabia has for a long time denied
the allegations that hijackers who
attacked the US on 911 were backed by
the Saudi government a royal family uh
we know that 15 of the 19 hijackers were
Saudi nationals so that is going to
change now you might say well there's
probably some other side to this right i
mean it sounds good if we have people in
saudi arabia that we believe were funded
by the saudi government we want to be
able to sue them what is being said as
the counter is that this really does
open up the door to the u.s. being sued
when americans go to other countries and
perpetrate acts of terror or criminality
abroad and that sort of like the main
opposition that we've been hearing to
this uh that that is sort of where
the the debate is mostly CIA director
John Brennan said that there are quote
grave implications for national security
because if this were to also be applied
to the US all of a sudden you have a
potential liability sort of hanging out
there that the United States could be
sued in similar ways as to the way in
which Saudi Arabia could potentially be
sued as a result of this veto override
within hours of the vote nearly 30
senators signed a letter expressing that
they have some reservations about the
potential consequences of the law
including that the u.s. could be sued in
foreign courts what's fascinating to me
about this when I step back number one
it's hard for me to imagine feeling
really strongly about uh taking Saudi
Arabia out of harm's way as part of our
vile and totally depraved alliance with
Saudi Arabia but I had another thought
which is when we think about the
trans-pacific partnership right one of
the things that TPP will do is it will
make it so that transnational
corporations rather than being sued or
litigated within one of the countries in
which they operate instead will be
brought to some kind of international
arbitration and this is very very
dangerous as progressives we should be
very concerned about that because it
allows these countries and major
corporations through the influence that
they have to set up a system where it's
going to be really really favorable to
them much more favorable to be favorable
to them than the justice system of any
particular country in which they operate
it is getting us our circumventing the
individual justice systems of individual
countries this has a similar issue like
we are talking about when you say well
now American citizens can sue the
country of Saudi Arabia without being
citizens of that country without being
legal residents of that country you were
also creating a sort of extrajudicial at
least when it comes to the country level
mechanism and that is something that we
need to think about big picture now I
know that it's different in TPP and in
what we're talking about here with suing
Saudi
we're talking about two different
mechanisms but big picture that's a lot
of what is uh at issue here which is
going above and beyond the rules of the
country in which one is a citizen or a
permanent resident and what the
potential implications of that will be
so this this is going to take some time
to shake out uh those are some of the
concerns that we've heard so far Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the sales person sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing